so welcome everyone uh today we're going
to talk about the 2022 virtual fall
training for undergraduate graduate
students and faculty and I'm going to
introduce three specific programs that
we are planning the first one is called
introduction to bioinformatics which is
really an overview of different types of
omics data that are commonly generated
in different types of research projects
it's less focused on the technical
aspect on how to perform the analysis or
what the data looks like and more
focused on getting biological insights
from those kinds of data sets
the second program is called data
science and that's focused on
visualization analysis and machine
learning it's quite a bit more technical
than the first one so we call that an
intermediate type program
it's really designed to help you learn
how to code how to load data visualize
different types of plots know how to
summarize and explore your data for
statistical analysis purposes and then
an introduction to machine learning so
what is supervised and unsupervised
methods of machine learning and how are
they used with different types of data
and different types of projects
the final uh Pro uh program that we're
we're gonna have is called
bioinformatics and biomedical research
and that is a more advanced program the
reason why it's more advanced is because
it's really focused on um analysis for
the purpose of developing a project so
this is going to be most relevant to
those of you that are either already
involved in bioinformatics research
or would like to be more involved in
bioinformatics research we'll talk about
some of the aspects of planning your
analysis making sure that your analysis
is reproducible uh performing analysis
using many different types of tools
including tools that you might have to
install on your computer use on the
cloud and maybe combine those tools
together and then we'll introduce you to
several examples of projects that others
have done using similar tools so you
have a framework on how to approach a
project of your own the ideal outcome of
this last Pro program is to develop a
project of your own and try to complete
it throughout the course of the program
so it's really driven by a biological
question of your own even though you
will have access to some interesting
ideas on how you might want to start
so um again as I mentioned in at the
beginning of the session you're welcome
to post any questions that you have in
chat I'll be happy to answer those and
then at the end we'll talk a little bit
more about how you might be able to get
more information about each one of these
programs
so first of all um I let me introduce
who we are uh Pine biotech is a team of
bioinformaticians and computer
scientists that have been working on the
topic of bioinformatics for quite a
while with partners that we have in
different academic institutions from
institutions like UCSF and Georgetown
University
institutions like University of Haifa in
Israel and institutions locally here in
Louisiana like the Louisiana State
University University of New Orleans
tooling University and others and one of
our objectives is to make bioinformatics
more user-friendly and make sure that
students starting from undergraduate and
all the way to faculty level can
effectively use bioinformatics tools as
we go about this topic we are also
trying to forge relationships that will
allow us to continue and expand the
number of programs that we can offer and
so we work with faculty at different
universities to actually take research
projects and different types of training
resources and adapt them to the same
Global community
last year we had a number of
participants from Louisiana but we also
expanded this training through the
National Association of idea principal
investigators and so this fall we're
going to try and offer the same program
across LSU partnering universities in
the Louisiana biomedical research
Network as well as others who are
interested in the National Association
of idea principal investigators member
universities and labs and so as you
might be coming from different research
organizations we will have to work with
you to get you signed up through the
right channel starting from Emmanuel who
is here who can help you if you are from
LSU or lbrn and then our team that
supports these programs that can contact
you by email and answer any questions
that you might have about that
so Amex logic uh covers six main topics
and this is an online portal
um it's free to sign up so anyone can
explore the different options that we
have there but these programs are going
to be guided and so we will have an
actual trainer the trainer um myself and
and partner of mine we will go through
the topics and try to answer some of the
questions that you might have but the
basic curriculum is organized around
these six topics which is an
introduction a high level overview of
different types of bioinformatics
methods genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and data
science and the way that we've organized
these topics is by providing case
studies in domains like oncology in
application to cancer studies infectious
diseases where we take bacterial and
viral diseases and kind of provide case
studies on how bioinformatics is used
there no neuroscience and agriculture or
biotechnology so those are the main kind
of pillars of the project studies or the
case studies that we have and so every
type of data and skill is then completed
with a case study or a project example
now one of our main goals is to make
sure that we have both the logic behind
the analysis which could be done without
any technical skills or coding as well
as additional kind of training on
introduction of what we consider to be
core skills in bioinformatics which
include a good understanding of
Statistics biostatistics data management
and I.T infrastructure for you know
being able to use high performance
Computing you know things like that and
also knowing how to code knowing how to
read code and knowing how to apply
typical functions that help simplify
some of the things that you have to do
in bioinformatics so that includes RN
Python and the way that that is
organized is we typically have a
pipeline from kind of the logic of the
analysis how do you organize different
steps of the analysis together to then
an introduction to the technical side of
how do these steps actually work and
then what are some applications how do
you know that you're doing the right
thing and where can you learn from
people that have done this in the past
and those are project examples
so before we begin
um what is going to be useful as we go
through today's presentation is to
create an account on our portal so the
portal link is learn.onicslogic.com
so that's the link and I'm going to uh
switch over to my screen to kind of
guide you on how to sign up
foreign
if you could
um also do it together with me so as a
result of today's session you also have
a
um an account and I'll kind of talk a
little bit about how this account fits
in with what we are going to be doing in
the next few months
so this is the portal
learn.omexlogic.com this portal has a
login button right here on the top so
we're going to click there
uh you can sign up with a social media
account or using your email we recommend
if you come from a university that is
going to participate in one of these
training programs to use your University
email that way we can easily link your
profile with your registration
so if you're from LSU I would you know
use your OSU account
if you're from another University you
can use that I already have an account
so I'm going to sign up with my account
and I'm going to pause here for just a
couple of minutes uh if you have trouble
registering you can let me know but
please take a couple of minutes to sign
up and let me know once you're signed up
by maybe
um putting something like number one uh
or yes or signed up in the chat so I
know to go on
oops
okay so thank you Melanie
um and again if you do not have the time
to sign up right now that is also fine
but it will be much more useful for you
to be able to navigate the site as we go
through
so again the sign up is free I recommend
using your email account from the
University that you are in that will
help us connect your profile with what's
happening in the program and what you
will notice is that right away as you
sign up you have a profile you will be
redirected to this page of the courses
and you will see your profile right here
and you can click right here on your
profile and complete it right away
because that's going to be the first
thing that you will be emailed about
is completing your profile so what does
completing your profile mean let me
switch back to my slides I'll kind of
take it from here so your profile is
really where all the information about
you about your activity and about your
accomplishments is going to be stored
you will have your profile picture which
you don't have to by the way use your
personal picture if you're not
comfortable sharing it you can use your
University logo or any picture that you
would like we recommend Connecticut
connecting your social media or orc ID
accounts because ultimately this is a
project-based portal so once you have
those projects you will be able to link
them to your academic or social media
account uh you will see that you will
have accumulation of points here as you
go through the different assignments and
training steps and those points
ultimately will lead you to an expert
level and that expert level is basically
10 000 points
we recommend adding a little bio that
allows people to know who you are for
example you might be a graduate student
in a particular school and learning or
interested in a particular topic and
then down here below you will have
badges assigned to you according to the
program that you're in so today we're
talking about three different programs
introduction to bioinformatics data
science and
bioinformatics and biomedical research
and so those badges will appear right
here
as you go through the different training
you will notice that we have
certificates and these certificates are
going to be essentially your validation
that you have completed a course which
is associated with a skill or a project
and also you will have these to show to
whoever is going to be evaluating your
progress at the end of the program
now as you are going through the course
page you can go back always to the
course page you will see that they are
organized in several different ways you
can first of all use the search bar to
be able to search for specific topics
like transcriptomics genomics r or
python or bioinformatics or machine
learning you can also navigate through
these tags on the side and you will see
how many different resources are
available or here we have collections
according to the different topics that
you might be interested in genomics
transcriptomics informatics and art T
bioinfo and others
now we do have a getting started package
or a collection
and we recommend to anyone who's
completely new to bioinformatics to go
through the collection of getting
started now ultimately whatever courses
you begin will appear under your profile
so you can see this is my profile and
under my profile I have started
introduction to my informatics and have
completed two out of six lessons or have
completed the transcriptomics
transcriptomics program or have not yet
started with bioinformatics for
infectious diseases and that is how you
know to go back and kind of start from
where you left off
now we use this point system to track
progress and for every activity like
completing your profile uh going through
a particular resource uh completing it
or submitting a project for example you
will be rewarded with points if you are
ever interested to see what is actually
going on you can always go to
um this tag right here achievements
and you will see in real time that all
of these achievements are actually seen
right here so David for example
um is completing some lesson on
experimental study design and some of
you have signed up and we can see that
right here so you'll be able to kind of
see what's going on and also explore who
are these people and see their level
intermediate beginner or expert
all right so
um after we have signed up and we have
completed our profile let me briefly
explain what are some of the program
resources that are going to be available
to you as you navigate these programs
so we will talk about different aspects
that are needed to be successful we
believe in this program and that will
include training materials data analysis
tools coding exercises and then project
examples that you can start from to be
able to begin your research using
bioinformatics
so um first of all let's talk about
um kind of how these tools are organized
so that you can effectively use them and
how you can get help from people that
have expertise in those tools so as I
mentioned one of our main goals is to
make bioinformatics more accessible more
user friendly and ultimately effective
in the hands of researchers whether they
are technically sound and trained or not
and so we want to bring kind of training
together with these user-friendly tools
to help you get farther ahead in a short
period of time
and to do that we have a number of
resources those resources are again
going to be linked to your profile so to
get started you don't need any
background or experience in
bioinformatics so if you don't know how
to code if you don't have any technical
experience that's fine but you will be
provided with a series of exercises that
you can go through to learn how to apply
some of those skills and this is going
to be based on real world case studies
taken from research literature you will
see that you will kind of go through the
same similar steps to what the
researchers do and you will be provided
with some training material to know how
to read or run different types of code
in both R and python along the way
producing the typical visualization or
analysis results that you see in those
case studies now in addition to having
these asynchronous resources we have a
community of experts that are working at
The Cutting Edge of bioinformatics
applying them in different areas of
research from cancer to different types
of forensic genomics and others and so
we regularly bring them together to talk
about what is the future of these kinds
of bioinformatics applications in
different areas of research and so we
host those twice a year this is our Amex
research Symposium and experts from
different domains come and discuss so we
kind of build a pipeline from training
to application to then interaction with
a network of mentors and um
experts in the field a critical resource
that you will have access to
um throughout the process that we're
describing is the T bioinfo platform
which allows you to follow logically
organized steps in bioinformatics using
different types of methods with a
user-friendly interface and connect them
to produce interactive outputs that then
help you explore the data
now further as you go through the logic
and practice you will also be given
pieces of code that you can adopt and
use in your own research that will help
you kind of have an organized library of
different coding exercises that you have
done collected and then you can take and
you know copy and paste from there to be
able to perform similar tasks as you
work on different projects so the first
program that I want to introduce you
today too is called introduction to
bioinformatics this is the very basic
course that you will be able to take and
just get started with bioinformatics so
I noticed that somebody is asking where
can you find this course this course is
a program that will last for
um you know will have some asynchronous
resources that I will explain now and
also we'll have some guided sessions
where somebody will be going through the
material and be able to answer your
question so if you're just getting
started you can do it on your own time
frame using the online resources on the
learn portal that we just went through
and I'll show you kind of a few lessons
that are included there and you can join
those sessions if you have any questions
you you're getting stuck and you need
some help or you just have uh you know
other interesting kind of applications
that will be covered so this is the
collection of courses under the getting
started tag that I just briefly showed
you on the main course page if you look
through the chat I also pasted the link
uh so if you just go to this link right
here
you will see on your left on your bottom
right side there's a collection of
courses called getting started and that
includes courses like introduction to
bioinformatics bytes and molecules
introduction to bioinformatics and R an
introduction to bioinformatics in Python
so the introduction to bioinformatics
gives you a very high level short course
to understand what bioinformatics is all
about and where is it used bytes and
molecules is a course that goes into a
little bit more detail and talks about
the terms that you need to know and
Concepts that you need to understand and
then bioinformatics and R and python are
introductory courses to just get you
started with the idea of running a
script loading some data and producing
some visual outputs really simple things
but something to get you started with
now the bytes and molecules course is
the central piece of information that
covers a lot of uh important concepts
related to bioinformatics and that is
from general concepts like what are
genes and proteins and things like that
and to more specific things like
different types of data like genomics
metagenomics and
epigenomics for example
um what we will try to do is give you a
conceptual high level overview of
different types of omics Technologies
and how they are used in different types
of projects it's not going to be very
in-depth but just a high level overview
now after you complete this basic
training we think that you will be
prepared to continue asynchronously with
the different resources that are
available on the learn portal and there
you will find projects that hopefully
are aligned with your interest so
whether you're interested in infectious
diseases agriculture biotechnology
biomedical research or others
with this you will have a demo account
on the T bioinfo platform a demo account
allows you to run pre-made pipelines and
those pre-made pipelines are an
excellent way to just understand what
are the different steps involved in
different types of data analysis
approaches for example
we'll talk about processing data
processing data is one of the critical
steps in organizing data that comes out
of a sequencing machine for example into
structured data that then could be
analyzed and so we'll talk about
different steps for analysis we'll then
talk about what to do with the data that
is structured and that typically
includes different types of outputs like
tables static or Interactive
visualizations
the platform has been evaluated by a lot
of users from uh undergraduate you know
beginner users all the way to experts in
the field and it provides an interface
that links different types of methods
that are written in different languages
in an environment that is
consistent and logically organized
the main idea behind the platform is to
organize different methods according to
the logical steps and then provide a
consistent interface that is you know
the same color coded across different
sections or different data types
uh the data types again as I mentioned
are going to be transcriptomics which is
a bulk rna-seq how to go through the
steps of processing rna-seq and
Performing Downstream analysis like
differential gene expression
um principle component analysis and
others and you will see that the
platform provides a user-friendly
dashboard that allows you to explore how
all of these different methods fit
together to help you understand your
data we'll talk about single cell
rna-seq a very hot topic today and may
many people struggle with kind of
organizing all of the steps into a
logical flow and so that will produce
standard outputs that will help you
interactively explore your data sets
we'll talk about metagenomics and
particularly we'll talk about the data
too and the chyme or chime too and that
you know how you can extract a taxonomy
level information from 16s ribosomal RNA
and then we will talk about
genomics as well so how you can process
complex data perform multiple sequence
alignment and do annotation of those
variants or sequences to understand the
relationship between the phenotypes and
the omics data that you have
finally we'll talk a little bit more
about how multiomics integration is a
new topic that oftentimes you know we
focus on how do we actually organize all
of this data so that it makes sense what
the project is all about and how can we
study systems biology using different
levels of omics Regulation so again this
first program will give you a high level
introduction to these different types of
omics data and we'll introduce you to
some of the other topics that we will
cover in the other programs that we will
have
the second program is uh more advanced
than the first one so it will focus on
some of the technical aspects of data
science how do we perform data
visualizations statistical analysis
machine learning in r or python for the
process data so in the first course the
beginner course you kind of learn about
how that data gets processed and gets
structured and here we'll talk about how
to use these methods to actually work
with the structured data organize it
manipulate it visualize it and infer
insights from complex data sets that are
available in our mix studies so we'll
start by these introductory courses
introduction to bioinformatics and R and
python where you understand the
relationship between strings matrices
how the data is stored and basic ideas
about visualization and then we will go
on to explore some of the standard
methods that are used to work with this
data how to store and work with this
data starting from data visualization to
then statistical analysis and then
finally machine learning which is an
important toolkit of commonly used
methods that are oftentimes applied to
different types of structured data from
numeric data that could be you know
biological data how many samples I have
in each category two more and more
complex data like single cell rna-seq
where you have thousands of cells with
tens of thousands of genes in each cell
type
so
um here the idea will be to understand
syntax
to be able to modify read and modify a
piece of code to get the types of
outputs that you need and then try to
apply it to different types of data sets
as well and this is organized by coding
challenges interactive notebooks that
will be given to you to modify and and
fix or do some assignments and those
assignments will be reviewed by a mentor
who is familiar with kind of best
practices and will help you organize
these notebooks
for your own portfolio so in the end you
should have a collection of
um Jupiter notebooks or essentially
notebooks that organize codes code in
different steps that are aligned with a
project where there's a question or a
problem statement then there is an
approach or an analysis uh maybe
exploratory analysis first then
comparative analysis and then finally
some biological conclusions
and so we'll use Google collab a useful
tool that allows us to share code and
also help you
um kind of overcome any challenges or
issues that rise along the way
um we are going to also conclude with an
overview of how all of the pieces or all
of the steps of analysis tie together
from experimental design all the way to
reproducible results that are based on
inference from the choices that you've
made along the way in your analysis of
the data
at the end you will be introduced to
project examples where we talk about
Diagnostics and cancer biology single
cell and tissue composition microbiome
and infection and that leads me to our
last program which is bioinformatics in
biomedical research so after you kind of
complete the introductory course which
is a high level overview then we go into
a more technical more advanced program
and that program allows you to
understand in depth what each step or
each method of analysis does and now in
this last program it is the application
how do you actually apply all of these
tools and methods to projects where you
are focused on getting results
so we're going to focus on areas of
biomedical research a lot of that will
be in neuroscience and oncology and
infectious diseases and we will talk a
lot about how these tools connect
together to actually get to the insights
uh that you can potentially publish or
present in a poster so the program is
oriented according to different topics
so for example the context could be
cancer right or as an example and there
you have different kinds of questions or
different kinds of situations like the
tumor microenvironment or heterogeneity
or Gene regulation and Target Pathways
for drug Discovery and then we will try
to link those ideas to bioinformatics
methods that are used in such research
like how to process data and prepare it
for variant calling or for gene
expression analysis and then all the way
to examples of how was this actually
done in a particular study and that
study again is sourced from a
publication where the publication
provides a framework of what the authors
did provides a data set and those are
curated data sets that are available
under projects on our portal and then
eventually we will also go into how how
to find such data on ncbi so publicly
available data sets that you can take
and structure your own bioinformatics
project as a result of the analysis that
you have done so the main kind of idea
of these projects is going to be how to
link clinical or kind of biomedical
subjects with Onyx data and how to
perform bioinformatics analysis of these
data to arrive at practical insights
now as I mentioned we have a high
priority for also those who do not feel
like they are technically capable of
addressing every step of the analysis so
it is going to be absolutely fine to
leverage the T by info platform kind of
understand the logic of what is
happening and then focus on the
downstream analysis of the process data
all the way to biological interpretation
using annotation databases like The Keg
pathway annotation for example and
others uh we will also try to introduce
projects that leverage Data Mining and
classification so you'll have some
examples of those as well but again the
focus is not going to be unnecessarily
technical deployment and understanding
of each method but more how are these
methods used in the types of studies
that we introduce
uh I think the Single Cell kind of
example is a great example of a very
important and useful technique that
allows us to take the research level
even lower to this single cell level
where a lot of technical questions arise
about you know how is data prepared how
is it then processed and importantly how
is it annotated and what kinds of
insights are reliable from these kinds
of studies so we'll talk a little bit
about how those types of projects are
done now I think the ideal outcome of
such training is to be able to complete
a project and we've done these projects
in the past a lot of them happen over
the summer but also throughout the year
I think the ideal outcome is when you
complete a project and are able to
present it and so I will briefly show
you
um let me just go to my uh profile here
I will show you what those projects look
like
so first of all if you go to your
profile so again remember your profile
needs to be completed after it is
complete and you have over 10 000 points
so for example here you can see that I
have over 27 000 points uh you will have
this section
unlocked for you called projects and
this is where you will be able to start
sorry a new project that is organized
according to the typical steps that you
would need to go through to make your
analysis reproducible and also to submit
your project for a poster presentation
or even prepare for a publication so
here you will have the chance to submit
a curated data set that you may be
organized from several studies that is
annotated and publicly accessible with
all the correct annotation write an
abstract
an introduction methods results
discussion conclusion references and
acknowledgments at the end and what
happens after you complete this process
is
um this project gets added to our
collection of projects that have been
completed we have quite a number of
those and you can explore them on this
link just to kind of understand what
these projects end up looking like now
we have this biannual event that is by
the way aligned with other events that
are happening throughout the Louisiana
biomedical research Network where these
types of projects are going to be
presented to
um expert mentors that can provide you
with important feedback about your
project about your approach about the
Innovation and about the results that
you produce and this could be a great
step to get started with a larger
research project maybe even working with
a mentor at the end of a program like
this
now not everyone is going to have a
project ready we hope that you do end up
with a project but to help you get
started we have curated some interesting
topics in biomedical research that you
can start with like modeling cancer
Precision medicine uh immune responses
in cancer
exosomes and others and so if you are
interested in more of such projects you
can go on the portal and research kind
of how others have done it or what are
some other topics that we have covered
there and if um you know hopefully that
we can also work with you to find you a
mentor to continue then and work on such
projects on your own now Beyond
biomedical research we do have these
projects organized according to these
different types of areas of Interest
which include Precision medicine
population Health biotechnology and
Agriculture and then space and
astrobiology another interesting and
exciting topic where a lot of publicly
available data sets is starting to be
made you know accessible through NASA
and other collaborators that the agency
has
so once you complete an example project
like that the key is going to be to
understand how to organize your process
from working on a data set that was
prepared for you to actually then start
developing a hypothesis that you could
work on uh looking at different publicly
available data sets and working on an
independent project and that includes a
specific process that we kind of cover
in one of the courses that is also
available on the portal that actually
guides you on how to perform these steps
and along the way you'll have some
opportunity to discuss some of these
steps with a more experienced Mentor
that can provide you with some feedback
and then finally complete the project on
your own
so I want to finish this review of the
different three programs that we just
talked about with an example of someone
that has completed two of these programs
and has
um in the end
um this to say so the program is very
well structured and easy to learn the
skills that I gained through the program
helped me significantly enhance the
relevance of my project by making
connections between my pre-clinical
study and its practical applications to
cancer patients and this was a quote
from Olga odartsova who was a research
affiliate a postdoc at Roswell Park
Comprehensive Cancer Center and since
then has joined a small biotechnology
company working on their pre-clinical
pipeline so I think that you know I hope
that this allows you to see kind of how
the structure of the programs is
organized what are some of the resources
that you will have access to and how you
can benefit from completing such
training in this upcoming fall season
with that I want to ask if there are any
questions and maybe introduce Emmanuel
who will be able to help you with any
technical questions about registration
or any other questions that you might
have so Emmanuel
hello
yeah so nice to meet you everyone my
name is Emmanuel and I am
um
the liaison between
lbrn and pan biotech on myclusic so I am
available for
any question for the pump for for any
help for
related to the different courses
and Emmanuel how do people actually
register where do they need to go if you
can just watch so if it's not already
done uh you will need to register to the
Red Cap link that I'm gonna find back
again
um and
um
follow that you will just need to open
your account I make logic we need the
red coupling register in order to
collect all the persons that are
affiliated to the lbrn campuses or for
the school of um Veterinary for LSU in
order to
it just for an accounting purpose so uh
yeah now it's more about how to connect
to the audit logic programs but for the
ones that haven't done it I think I
haven't so much but yet please do do
feel this Red Cap form that I'm gonna
find back the link and for all the
person that I have
um give a personal email I will
appreciate that you give your
institutional email because it's all
proof that you are affiliated to the to
the com the university so thank you
it's all right thank you Emmanuel now if
you still don't have your Red Cap link
which we will post here in the chat um
very soon you can also use this form uh
which will you know just put your email
and registration on our database and we
can reach out to you
um you know with next steps
excuse me yeah yes go ahead if you if
you if you are interested to get
directly into these research projects is
it possible or not or do you need to
have to go through some prerequisites
for some programs
as you mentioned
um yeah so I think the research project
is something that does require some
background in bioinformatics it's very
difficult I think to just you know learn
everything and then also do a project of
your own
um so we we do recommend to go through
at least the introduction to my
informatics to get started
but if you have these Basics and you
wanted to just jump directly into this
oh yes yes is it okay yes yes if you
have already the basics yes you can jump
into the research project and also if
you have an account already by just a
private email is it possible to change
it into University email or is it or do
you need to have a new registration then
I think it is better to do a new
registration unfortunately because you
know if you already if if you haven't
done any coursework or anything like
that then I think you might be able to
change that uh maybe you can share your
email address I will share with our
technical team and they will reach out
to you about changing your email I think
they will be able to do it on the back
end
thank you so much
and uh Emmanuela was asking about the
university and Emmanuel replied yes you
can just pay a program fee by yourself
so again I would recommend if you're not
affiliated with the Louisiana biomedical
research or a nappy University
you can go to this link and our team
will reach out to you about the next
steps on on how you can participate
okay and so if no one else has any
questions again we have recorded this
session it's going to be made available
we will follow up by email and send it
to you if you do have any questions you
can reach us
um this is my email address uh and then
Emmanuel if you want to share yours
so we can directly help you with
Emmanuel is the coordinator for the
Louisiana biomedical research Network so
she can answer any of those questions we
did send an email invitation to
participants from nepi so if you're not
from Louisiana then you can email me or
our team that can also help you and that
is sparsh she's available on marketing
at Pine
find that bio
and you know if you fill out the forms I
mentioned on that link we'll be
following up with you to send you
additional information by email
all right Emmanuel thank you for your
help
thank you you're welcome and if anyone
has any questions again reach out to us
by email and have a great weekend
everyone
okay there's one yes
um okay yes good questions thank you
Melanie Emmanuela so Emmanuela you can
reach out to me
um yes we have a team a support team uh
that will be monitoring your progress
and you can definitely
um reach out to them so support pine.bio
is the email for them
when does the program actually begin
uh that's a great question Emmanuel do
you know the answer to that
no
uh so if I initially before we moved the
orientation there it was on the 19th
20th of October but maybe he'd have
moved on so I don't know
yes I think we are going to let me just
check the
um
I think that it is going to be you know
like the 19th or in the end of October
is when it starts we're gonna have our
next orientation session like today
um next week another one uh just because
there was a little bit of a delay of
getting everything approved and if you
registered already Melanie then we will
send you that by email
um next week
and hopefully excuse me again
yes how's the broker how's the program
is going to be organized
how's the program is going to be
organized how many sessions
approximately 10 sessions per program
yes timing consistent
and the timing is going to be similar to
now so it's going to be three to four pm
Central Time
yeah it's just it's going to be just
lecturing or have some practice or what
kind of communication
yeah there's going to be some lecturing
some Hands-On practice and a guide on
how to complete the assignments online
asynchronously as well
yes Melanie hello
we can't hear you
all right I don't have a question sorry
I just didn't want to be a faceless so I
got it okay well thank you and now we
know what you look like and
um
hello turns yes we can't hear you
I'm sorry about that I didn't have my uh
my mic on so the omnim the link City
omnim group chat that you in the chat
that you send those are for like
practice problems and everything like
that and that can be for particularly
anybody that's interested in
bioinformatics at any level
yeah the links uh that I shared so
there's one link which is the actual
portal the omics logic portal is for
anyone you can start for free uh there
are some additional small subscription
charge after you go through more
advanced topics and the programs that I
described are going to leverage some of
those online asynchronous resources but
they will include a lecture style
presentation with some Hands-On
exercises that are done together in a
group session
all right and the registration part was
for the LSU biomed form
yeah so if you are you at LSU or one of
the lbrn uh University oh yes David
University of Louisiana yes
okay so yes you are then uh the purpose
of the registration is just for us to
have your contact information the real
place where you have to register to
participate is with the Red Cap form
that Emmanuel shared
um and that is a form to get you um into
that program uh for free uh covered by
Louisiana biomedical research network if
you qualify
all right thank you
all right so hopefully we did answer all
of the questions now I'm going to stop
the recording